largement répandue j'avoue mon système
il ya une seule échelle de valeur ils
ont géré le succès dans notre société ce
que messi réussir les examens à
l'université atteindre l'intérieur comme
meetic plus ou moins réussie que si l on
revient un peu en arrière pour deux
personnes avec ce genre de parcours et
le sens où j'ai été passer également
répandu aujourd'hui n'ont qu'une seule
grande échelle qui nous permet
d'atteindre la sécurité du succès et
cette échelle je passe par l'université
ou de petite échelle différence beaucoup
de façons différentes et d'obtenir du
succès du testing
oui je pense qu'il faut se la payer à
nouveau une nouvelle page s'ouvre sur
différents axes que réussie mais il faut
apprendre à une personne il faut être
une personne travailleuse semble facile
à déterminer mais bien d'autres
compétences le plus difficile à mesurer
si on demande un économiste pourquoi le
travailleur dans les maisons de retraite
sonnée monde et comme dirt n si mal
payés avec lors que l'on se répondre ah
parce que emile kima parti qui pourrait
le faire ce que tu lis je veux dire
c'est que anglo le niveau de
qualification mais très bonne position
pour y travailler mais tous il suffit de
passer dix minutes dans un hôpital où
une maison de retraite
on sait tous que de bonzac soignants et
il y à 12 aides soignants qui ne font
pas bien leur travail mais on ne fait
pas la différence entre ces différentes
personnes et pourtant le devrait
[Musique]